oh
[Silence]
continuing
continuing this evening
in the book
of z
authored by the
esteemed late scholar of islam
we were discussing and
we were in the continuation of
discussing
the manner in which the prophet muhammad
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would pray
we had discussed all the way up until
a tesleem meaning how the prophet
[Arabic recitation]
alaihi wasallam would exit prayer
how he would end it and the way that he
would end
prayer is by turning his head
a full 90 degrees
while saying
usually this is the phrase
turning the head 90 degrees to the right
and then
again 90 degrees to the left
we mentioned four different ways
that it was recorded that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
however the majority of the time
when he would be leading the companions
to each side the right and left
likewise mentions
saying to the right only
and that in this regard he would turn
his head
after having said assalamu alaikum
he would turn his head to the right 45
degrees and this is found in the
narration of
which is collected by imam tirmothy and
others
however
mentions that this is regarding
only prayer at night when he would be
praying alone most of the time
now discussing some of the things that
the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would say
just before he would make his tesleem
just before he would exit prayer after
he had finished
after he had finished making a salah
upon
himself with what is known as
in which he taught the companions one of
the companions had
asked the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
we know how to give you salam so how do
we make a sale upon you
he responded
[Silence]
this is one way this of course
is a well-known narration collected in
all of the
six books of hadith however there are a
number of wordings
we mentioned that the principle with
regards to
dua and wikir that the scholars
mention is that they may not be
they may not be narrated by the meaning
they have to be narrated by the wording
the wording has to be exact what does
that mean
well when the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
would say something the companions would
memorize what he would say this
memorization
usually consisted of verbatim
exactly these words is what he said
however there is a little bit of leeway
there
where some words may be
exchanged for others of the same
meaning this is what is known as
is that a person
narrates a narration by the meaning of
the narration the spirits of the
narration the general
rough wording so for example
if i were to say a simple sentence like
please open the door all right
well someone may narrate that as please
open the door which is verbatim
and others may narrate that as open the
door please
or would you please open the door or
may i ask you to open the do all of this
is the same general meaning it has the
same
spirit this is this is valid in hadith
and
invalid in the quran the quran has to be
recited exactly as it was revealed
and this is why the scholars of islam
do not base extremely
precise rulings generally on the exact
wording of a hadith as we do in the
quran in the quran
there are certain word and grammatical
structures that articulate
certain things that are beyond what is
said
those things are extrapolated from the
quran
and to a lesser degree from the sunnah
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam because of this
reason
but however this
is permissible according to the majority
of the scholars of islam of ancient
classical and contemporary that
a person may narrate the narration of
the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam by the meaning
so we will find let's take a very famous
narration
in this is a narration that many people
know
is one way it was narrated
this narration has been narrated amongst
the scholars of hadith and it all
has essentially the same meaning and so
this is permissible in the hadith of the
prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam except in athkar
and adeya in athkaran it must be
verbatim it must be exactly
as it was heard from the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and so because of this
when a person wishes to make it to there
are a number of ways
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam worded
any one of those ways which we collect
from a narration
that is authentic is permissible to say
it but not
outside of that we cannot we cannot
mention it more or less the same thing
with us upon the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam there are a number of
evidences for this
principle but one of the main evidences
is the narration
in which the prophet this salallahu
is collected by imam muslim in which the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam was
teaching
what to say just before he goes to sleep
at night
he says
[Silence]
so this is the narration it mentions
that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam instructed that when you
go to sleep
that when you reach your you need to
make wudu as you would for prayer
lay on your right side and then say and
he taught him this
somewhat lengthy dua at the end of the
dua
the last phrase the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam instructed him to say
amen to
i have believed in the book your book
which you have sent down
and i have also believed in your prophet
that you have sent
al-barrah said let me repeat it back to
you to make sure that i have it
correctly
and so al-bara ibn azib repeated it
exactly
except at the end he said
amen to be kitab
i have believed in your book that you
have sent down
and i have also believed in your
messenger which you have sent
the prophet
do not say your messenger that you have
sent rather say your prophet that you
have sent
now this is something that
the scholars of islam derive from this
narration and others it that
the dua that we make that
are
certain right these things have to be
verbatim
what is the difference between your
messenger that you have sent and your
prophet that you have sent
well it's more or less the spirit
of it is the same but the wording does
articulate a slightly different meaning
and that meaning was something that
was dwelled upon by the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
so what is the point of all of this the
point is is that in our prayers
anything that we say that
is part of the structure of the prayer
the scholars of islam have divided
all acts of worship into
conditions and pillars right conditions
and pillars
conditions of salah include that the
time of prayer is
in conditions of include facing the
qibla
intention etc there are in the correct
opinion 9
9 conditions of prayer and then there
are
pillars which there are 14
pillars of prayer and
these conditions and these pillars mean
that
the prayer is integrally
sound with these present without any of
these the prayer cannot be valid
provided normal circumstances
hence these pillars of prayer
such as this is a pillar of prayer
allah muhammad muhammad
[Arabic recitation]
reciting
as well a tesleem to the right and to
the left
these are verbal pillars of prayer they
have to be done exactly as they were
narrated from the prophet salallahu
you can choose any wording of those
wordings
however it has to be a chosen wording
that you stick to
from the authentic books of hadith
he says
now is mentioning some of the other
some of the other supplications that the
prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam
would make at the conclusion of his
prayer
meaning just before teslim after he
[Silence]
he would make is that which translates
to oh allah
now this is before teslim so he is
now sitting he has just finished
making a salah ibrahimiya his finger is
still
in the way that we had described he is
still engaged in prayer
and one of the idea that he would make
would be this one and it translates to
oh
allah i seek refuge in you from the
punishment
of the grave and i seek refuge in you
from the
from the trial and tribulation
of the false messiah and i also seek
refuge in you from the trials of this
life and the hereafter and the trials of
death
oh allah i seek refuge in you
from sinfulness and from
debtedness and so
this here from sinfulness and from loss
now this here is one of the ad that he
would make
so
allah forgive me my sin
make spacious for me my residence
and place your blessings
in that which
[Silence]
and he would likewise say that which
translates to
oh allah i do indeed
ask ask of you that you keep me
firm in all of my affair i ask you
solemn resolve in pursuing
enlightenment and guidance and i ask you
that you make me of those who are
thankful
for the blessings you have bestowed upon
me
i as well ask that you
grant me perfection in my worship of you
i ask of you as well that you grant me
a sound heart and
that you grant me as well an honest
and truthful tongue i as well ask you
from the best of that which you know to
be
and i seek refuge in you from that which
you know to be
evil or bad and i seek
refuge in you from all that
and i seek forgiveness in you from all
that you know
meaning of my sin
beloved and what we know
of what has been narrated of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam's
supplications in salah is that these
supplications
would be worded in the singular meaning
he would be asking for himself
rather than oh allah grant us
his wording would often be oh allah
grant
me a
now this is what is in a
in a person's prayer that is particular
to him
as for a person's prayer in which he has
people praying behind him
then the person must reword whatever it
is he is making dua for to include those
who are praying with him
and what i'm speaking about is
general dua that is audible to those who
are praying behind a person so let's say
right and ramadan the imam is making dua
the imam is not going to stand in front
of a crowd of people who are praying
with him
and say oh allah forgive me o allah
grant me rather it is forgive us grant
us right and this is
part of the etiquettes of prayer
likewise one of the etiquettes of prayer
as was
narrated by jabber
in a sunnah that when the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam would make
dua for himself
and someone else he would begin with
himself
right so for a person to make dua
for someone else alone say oh allah
forgive so and so
that's fine but when he would make dua
for
himself and someone else he would always
start with himself
so he would begin with himself
are these things integral to prayer no
they are not integral
meaning that the supplication will be
acceptable
however this is the proper these are
some of the etiquettes
of making dua
[Silence]
is speaking about where the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
sight would be while he is in prayer
right
he says in the standing position
he would usually lower his head right
we don't have any definitive narrations
speaking those narrations
are of two types they are either
authentic
but vague
or they are explicit but inauthentic
of where he would look when he is in the
standing position
so there is for instance a narration
that mentions that he would look
at his place of sujud in the standing
position in salah
however this narration is not
strong enough to negate anything else
mentions that
it was narrated that when he would stand
for prayer he was low he would lower his
lower his head right not dangle his head
right rather he's in prayer he would
lower his head
and this is
an expression of humility in prayer
right that a person lower his head
just as it is an expression of arrogance
that a person raised his head
in prayer this is definitively
impermissible
as the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
has warned against a person
on rafael basari i need to raise a
person's
gaze towards the heavens while he is in
prayer this is something which is
impermissible
yet we do have definitive text
which mentions that in tashahud
his vision would be concentrated on his
finger his index finger of his right
hand
that he is making dua with
allah
that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam's favorite thing
to do was to pray and the bulk of his
blissfulness and pleasurefulness was
found in prayer
and he would say to bilal when he wanted
him to
when he wished to indicate for bill
which is his
which was his main in medina
that
when he wished to indicate to him to
make the akama to establish prayer he
would say
grant us comfort through prayer meaning
make the
karma so that we can go to that
comfortable place
of blissfulness and prayer right
yes
this
concentration in prayer
was something that would not take away
from his
focus on the people praying with him
that they be praying properly
that they exhibit the proper etiquettes
in prayer
yet he would maintain his focus as well
in prayer he says
and sometimes the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would initiate
prayer in congregation leading people in
salah
and his intention were to be to
make that particular prayer a bit
lengthy
but then something would come up during
the prayer
such as a child that he would hear that
was crying
and so he would resort to
shortening the prayer after having
previously
intended to lengthen it shortening it
what does that mean
shortening the things that are not
integral to the prayer
such as the recitation of the quran
after surah al-fatiha
a long chapter a short chapter etc all
of the extras that would
add on to the length of the prayer he
would then cut those out
because he would not want to
place any unnecessary stress on the
mother of that crying child
because she's in prayer and her child is
crying she's going to be
she's going to be praying
without being fully
lucid of what it is she is doing in her
prayers
likewise he would pray
occasionally the obligatory prayer
meaning is
whilst holding his granddaughter
umami on his
on his shoulder right he would have her
holding hers
as an infant and be praying as well
if he would be in the standing position
he would carry her in her in his arm
and when he would go to make roku or
sujud he would lay her on the floor
in front of him of course this is a
little infant right a little baby
we're not speaking about a child that
is wild and going to run around and jump
all over the muslin we're speaking about
an infant
that is small enough that
it's not going to move if you place her
down on the ground
he says
[Silence]
and sometimes he would be in prayer
and the opposite would happen he would
intend to
have a shorter prayer but then one of
his grandchildren may come up
can't come around very very young
and jump onto his back while he is in
sejud
and so he would lengthen his sujud
even though he had not prior he had not
planned to do so prior because he would
not want to
sit up and have the
child fall off of his back
and likewise sometimes he would be in
salah and aisha would arrive back at
home
and in order to open the door he would
walk
while he is in prayer open the door and
then return to his original place of
prayer
this of course is while maintaining a
person's
direction towards the qibla right
so i'm praying the door is over here to
my right
it's not a football field away it's just
you know a few steps and so he would
take a few steps to the door to open it
for her
and then return back this will not
interrupt the prayer this is not
enough movement that would warrant the
invalidity of his
prayer see
what the scholars agree on there are
about six invalidators of prayer
other scholars mention more than six
however
one of those that they all agree on is
too much movement excessive movement
what is excessive
movement when we say excessive movement
we're speaking about movement that does
not
serve the prayer movement
this is very important it is movement
that does not serve the prayer
right so for example
let's say a person goes into sujud
and there are some stones or rocks
underneath him and so he
straightens this out this serves the
prayer
correct this is for the prayer to be
better
right likewise
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
opening the door for aisha so that she
doesn't keep
knocking on the door and disturbing his
prayer he's neither praying
nor is she entering the house at that
point it's it's just
right so these things which
serve the prayer this is not what is
intended
with regards to excessive movement when
the scholars mention
excessive movement that will invalidate
a person's
prayer as when a person
does additional things that do not serve
the prayer they are just habitual
movements right a person is
standing in prayer and he's fixing
himself
up and he's playing with his beard and
he's playing with his fingers and all
this stuff a lot of people to play
with their feet
a lot of imams when they're leading
salad they to move their head
around and jerk it as they're reciting
all of this is what the scholars are
speaking about
they are speaking about this excessive
movement
now how much excessive movement will
invalidate the prayer
it's a difference of opinion some
scholars say three
some say five there's not really any
number
right the real yardstick
is that a person moves so much that
they're no longer considered to be
praying anymore
if i were to walk in and see you it
would look you're just standing
there
you know straightening your clothing you
can you no longer
look a person who is in prayer
anymore
and so this is
something that will invalidate a
person's prayer in this sense
so let's say a person is in salah
and some poisonous animal
or some insect or some something comes
up and is going to crawl up his leg
should he just stand there
a statue and wait for it to bite
him
or should he try not to move or what
should he do
that a person can move shoot away
if it's something that's poisonous kill
it right
and continue in his prayer this is
something that serves the prayer
this is not what is intended in that
wakanda ishara
and he would likewise respond to assalam
with his a gesture of the hand
which means that he would be praying
someone come in is
he would respond that right with
his hand
this is something which is disliked
outside of saleh
for a person to merely use the hand
now if a person uses the hand and mouths
this is the sunnah right
so for example
a brother is all the way at the end of
the masjid
right and we make eye contact
is it appropriate for me to raise my
hand
and say yes and raise my voice all the
way some some better we in the
masjid
of course not this is this is
inappropriate right to raise a person's
voice in the masjid
in this way however
the sunnah would be to raise the hand so
that that person can visualize that you
are acknowledging
his presence and to say
to yourself assalamu alaikum right this
is the way that the prophet salallahu
wasallam
would make salam to people who were
behind something behind some glass in a
car
driving by too far away for it to be
appropriate for me to raise my voice
say assalamu alaikum just that
however what is prohibited
is to just have the hand movement right
or the head nod people to do and
walk
by and you know this is not something
which is for the muslims
right muslims have assalamu alaikum
and so yes all of this is permissible
however as conveying a salaam
by way of gesture is permissible if it
accompanies
movement of the lips as imam and nawa
rahimahullah is mentioned in his book
otherwise if a person is in an
appropriate distance the correct thing
is to say
even if the person is in salah right
it's mentioned in al musnet
that the ansar would enter the masjid
and convey assalam to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
while he is in prayer kanel ansar
[Silence]
so it is permissible to say assalamu
alaikum to someone who is in prayer
and the way that they respond is with
the hand gesture
and as for the narration which has been
narrated by some in which it's alleged
the the the
the the operating word there is
alleged
that the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam said
whoever communicates
by way of gesture while he is in prayer
then his salah must be repeated
this narration is a fabrication it is
not authentic
[Silence]
and so in general gesturing and prayer
will not
disturb the prayer right if a person
must gesture
how is that for example
one of the gestures of prayers if
somebody is going to walk in front of
you while you're praying
you gesture to them that i'm in prayer
don't walk in front of me
another gesture would be you know to
gesture to your child to do something or
something of that sort
this as long as it is something which is
very brief just a movement of the hand
similar to the salaam
then this is fine it is okay to interact
with someone
to this degree that is not impermissible
he says and the prophet
wasallam would sometimes blow during his
prayer the karahu ahmed as was recorded
by ahmed
what does that mean well you know
there's something let's say an ant
on your hand or something to blow it off
or
to some necessary reason whatever that
is that is permissible and it's
something that
had occurred with the prophets
likewise it was narrated that he would
weep or cry during prayer
and likewise what is an
is clearing a person's throat right
this is a nanaha
and this is something that he was also
narrated to have done
for any need to do so
is
this is something that is unfortunately
misunderstood by many
al-qaeda says the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would occasionally
prayer pray
barefoot right and
other times he would pray wearing his
footwear
whatever that is whether it be the hard
leather
socks or what we would call socks
in the time of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
is a type of leather sock that would not
be worn with the shoe
this is something that ani and
katherine
mccann is
many people see this
is this is something that we can take a
little bit of a detour
and speak about and that is the issue
of
having half of the information
right conjecture and that is that
incomplete knowledge on any subject or
issue
is equivalent to ignorance only
it is more dangerous than ignorance why
because
you think that you know what you are
doing but you actually don't this is the
danger of it
[Silence]
is the true enemy of knowledge the true
enemy of knowledge is not ignorance
people learn
the true enemy of knowledge is
compounded
ignorance that a person doesn't know
something
and they are unaware of the fact that
they don't know about that thing they
they're under the impression that they
understand it and this is one of the
biggest plagues that
the muslim ummah is facing today it's a
very dangerous thing
and this is what has caused us to lose
the spirit
of islam in our hearts and in our lives
and so one of the issues
you know there it reminds me of a
statement
by islam
he said
he said four types of people will
completely ravage and destroy any nation
[Silence]
he says the four types of people will
completely destroy
any nation he says a half
of a philosopher meaning they're not an
expert they're not totally ignorant
they're just half
right they have half halfway mark of
knowledge
a half of a philosopher or logician
a half of a doctor a half
of a jurist and a half of a gr of a
of a of a linguist he says
[Silence]
we
he says a half of a philosopher or
logician will destroy people's beliefs
and a half of a jurist will destroy
people's
worship and a half of a grammarian
will destroy people's language
and a half of a doctor will destroy
people's
bodies right this won't be anything left
to the human being after that
this is this is the danger and so we
have a lot of haves
haves you know
the scholars would call them abu shibir
abu shibit is what
the guy who thinks that he knows
everything but he's really very he's
just beginning
[Silence]
this is how they would say in the books
of of hadith
and so the point here is that it's
important that if we
learn something that we learn it
completely right
not that we just take a little bit of it
and then we just go
one of that one of those
is the issue of wiping
over leather socks right
wiping over leather socks
so when we read the books of the fukuha
the especially the ancient or classical
works
we find that
it is not permissible to wipe over in
over anything that is less than leather
socks this is how the translation will
be
leather socks so what do we understand
when we understand the word
leather socks well we understand what
you see
in stores today right you can go into
certain stores
that sell you know muslim garb whatever
that is
and you'll find that they have these
socks made out of this very nice
lamb skin it's very soft right
and you can put that on and people
purposely
look for those socks and order them
and wear only those socks
why because they want to wipe over them
and solo right
but the problem with this is is that
that is not
what a hoof is right
a hoof is not something that is worn
with other footwear echo takes the place
of shoes
in the time of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi a real
hoof that was worn in the time of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was made out of hard leather
that when you would stand it up it would
stand up on its own
right and you would put it on and you
would walk for miles and miles and miles
this is what it was it took
takes the place of an alain
this hoof that is sold in these stores
that you've got to go and you've got to
pay money you got to look for it
otherwise i can't wipe i can't practice
my religion without this type of sock
this according to the scholars of islam
all of them is not a hoof this is not a
leather sock as it were this is
something else
right they specifically mentioned that a
hoof is something that must stand on its
own others mentioned that you must be
able to walk
a number of kilometers in it without it
breaking apart of course that does not
apply to these
leather socks this is not something you
walk down the street wearing
alone right and so
this is an example of
right we got the hadith and we got the
translation and whoever decided to
translate that just said you know
leather socks
gave us an idea and then we create this
thing that has nothing to do
with what the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam was actually speaking about
right this is this is the danger
of taking our
religious knowledge from
other than its proper sources and this
is one of the signs of the hour
the prophet salallahu wasallah mentioned
that
is that knowledge will be taken from the
young
and what is meant by the young heroes
[Silence]
this is a very dangerous thing and
unfortunately it's becoming more and
more commonplace
because of the sheer amount of platforms
that people have
to be able to reach listeners
right so there was a time when these
things were vetted
if i wanted to write a book i would
write a book
but if the scholars of islam didn't view
it being worthy
it would just fall into obscurity nobody
would
lie attenual and it would just die a
natural death
but now you know
you can do everything you can speak to a
huge audience and
unfortunately the more crazy people
speak the more
audience they have which is another
quark of our time
right
yeti
and this is the problem that we have
so when we read a book
when we understand the narration when we
read the quran
we need to make sure that we are
understanding it
the way that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam understood it and
intended it
right so for example
is
[Silence]
it's the type of ants that is so tiny
you can barely see its feet it just
looks a dot that's
moving we've seen this before right this
is called
the jammer with
[Silence]
this has nothing to do with what was
intended in the actual words of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi
and so what we have is explaining the
quran
which is in classical arabic
with modern colloquial
arabic this is one of the most dangerous
things that could ever happen to the
ummah
which is to to lose our language
right we will
stop there tonight we'll continue next
week inshaallah
finishing up on some of the issues of
prayer
and we will also discuss some of the
invalidators of prayer as well
in order to be on the same page
foreign